[Music]
hello everyone so today i'd like to
share with you all some things that i've
been working on at the piano regarding
contrary motion i've written three
exercises that are increasing in
complexity from one to three but before
i do that i'd like to share with you all
some tips that i keep in mind regarding
the layout of the keys and also some
things about outlining
so i hope you enjoy it so quite simply
looking at the layout of the keys we see
three black keys followed by two
three two three we're going to first
focus on the outer white notes
of the groups of three
so let's take our middle three fingers
and place them on the group of three
black keys
then our thumbs will be in place for
the outer notes and we're just going to
be using our thumbs so we're basically
playing either an f or b
[Music]
next we're going to add in the groups of
two notes which we'll be using
these two fingers
so now let's just do the black keys
[Music]
next add in the f's and the b's what we
were playing with our thumbs
[Music]
and the reason why i use f sharp major
is because there is a very obvious
physical layout and visual layout that
you can easily grab onto
[Music]
now when you get into other types of
patterns and different scales such as c
lydian
what happens in contrary motion is not
like the f sharp major scale where
it's in symmetry
so for example if we start on
the third degree and go outwards
[Music]
the black keys don't happen at the same
time which can throw you off so now
we're going to broaden the scope of how
we organize each little group
[Music]
so here's a simple pattern it sounds
like this
now with both hands
[Music]
so there are many ways to look at this
but i'm going to be looking at it in
three parts part one
part two
and then part three is also
c d e f sharp g
and that's an easy way to remember this
[Music]
now let's move on to a slightly more
complicated pattern
[Music]
so again let's divide it into three
parts first of all these five notes
again
and now here it's a little different
because in the right hand we have a
second inversion
major triad
[Music]
and then the left hand we have a first
inversion minor triad
and the last part
of course the notes are different than
the first exercise that i just showed
but the grouping in my head is the same
i'm still thinking about this as these
five notes
i'm thinking of the pattern
three one two five
so that i'm not thrown off by the black
key here and the black key with my
fourth finger
so again
[Music]
now we're going to move on to a more
complicated pattern and in this one
unlike the other ones i'm not going to
be mirroring the hands in an exact way
and i will be explaining why
[Music]
so the pattern consists of 10 notes
which are then repeated
so if we're going to be mirroring our
hands in an exact way following the
notes of
c lydian it would sound like this
[Music]
which sounds okay but in my opinion it
could sound a little better so in
looking at this pattern going inwards we
first start with b's on
each end
that sounds okay but again i don't like
it because
the c lydian sound is not as strongly
implied because of this b base
so i want to change that so we're going
to
start with the c so now after deciding
to start with the c in the left hand
i'm just going to be composing a counter
line to this line going backwards
and that's how i came up with
now with a pattern like this what i'm
latching onto is not as
neatly organized as the three groups for
example of the last exercises
so for this specific exercise the first
group that i'm thinking of is a little
bit broad
it's this group here but i'm focusing
mainly on the octaves
[Music]
after that i'm focusing on these lines
[Music]
and in addition to that i'm focusing on
the d and the c
[Music]
and i like that because it's a little
offset
and my ears latch onto that
[Music]
now i'm going in the opposite direction
the groups that i'm thinking of remain
the same
[Music]
[Music]
by the way i've written about five other
sets of these exercises using different
modes but i'd like to add just a few
more before i release the pdf anyway
thanks so much for watching and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
you